There are three statements here that are true.
The first one is true because f(n) clearly grow slower than g(n),
so g(n) grows at least as fast as f(n).
The second one is also true because h(n) grows even faster, so it outgrows f(n) also.
The f(n) here is the slowest growing function, so it does not outgrown g(n),
but h(n) on the other hand that is the fastest growing function so it does outgrow g(n).
This one here is true also, and since h(n) is the fastest growing function,
it's neither in O(f(n)) or in O(g(n)).
You can see the slowest growing function is always contained in O of the two
faster-growing functions and the fastest growing function is not contained in
either O(f(n)) or O(g(n)), which are growing slower.